let me pull up the story uh this is a
tweet from NPR highlighted by Libs of
tick tock who said that uh NPR's big mad
that genderqueer is being banned NPR
wrote in 2020 the book genderqueer
received multiple honors and was headed
for a fourth printing by Spring of 2022
it topped the ala's list of most
challenged books and you know why
I I can't show it on YouTube
I I the NPR article doesn't show it
there are graphic sexual images in that
book and they're an Amazon listed is 18
plus everybody knows we have it right
here yeah check it out it's right there
it's it's Ian Ian got it and I can pull
up the image there's there's a few Wow
have you ever you know this one right
yes of course I know this I I'm I can't
even I know it's that proves that we're
in dystopian world I am I am looking
right now at I can't even show it but
but you guys mostly know and this is the
crazy thing because people need to see
they need they need to see this book was
being given to kids and so this whole
thing this book not only do I believe
its intent is to groom children by
exposing look they say it's 18 plus on
Amazon but they're giving it to grade
schools and that's why it's being
challenged introducing kids to Kink it
is not reproduction it is not sex ed it
is kink it is kink advocacy because
they're showing toys and prosthesis and
things like that to children
this is part of grooming and radical
gender Theory which is resulting in as
we were just talking about men not
protecting women one the attack on
masculinity you know masculinity is a
fantastic thing and so is femininity
they are they are it's yin yang they are
two pieces of this great puzzle of of
the world they complement each other but
for some reason now I mean I assume I I
know many people can just assume the
reason the narrative is that one side is
extremely awful and bad no matter what
and so what you end up with is men who
don't want to be masculine they're being
told to wear dresses they're being told
to be effeminate and this results in men
not standing up and protecting women it
results in women then being victimized
it results in women then advocating for
a world and policy and law in which they
have no protection from males and so
it's it's akin to gun law in this way in
the city of Chicago you can't have guns
like you sort of can it's very very
difficult what happens rampant gun crime
people being shot left and right but
good innocent law-abiding people can't
have guns in terms of radical gender
Theory it results in good humbly
masculine men being unable to stand up
for what they believe in to protect
women and children and even other men
and it results in the most toxic and
evil men exploiting and taking advantage
of women with with no hindrance it's
anti- future I think I've heard Lou say
this before and I agree with him when he
says like we're more in like a cultural
revolution in terms of like Mao in the
60s with China and when I see this stuff
with what they're doing to children I
see it as like a way for them to destroy
the future like Mao destroyed the past
and a lot of Chinese culture language
art statue stuff like that
um to then recreate the future and then
by destroying the innocence of children
they are literally destroying the humans
of the future
um and that's like so scary because I'm
watching kids young kids who are
inheriting nihilism from their parents
who refuse to stand up to do anything
against the bad stuff and it's just like
well you're screwed because how do you
fix that how do you fix nihilism in a
nine-year-old you know you know what I I
I view myself as a positive nihilist
yeah and there's negative nihilist let
me explain so I can give you a very
rudimentary understanding of nihilism
basically like how would you describe it
nothing matters total meaninglessness
totally meaninglessness but hold on hold
on I don't disagree with that I take it
to a positive Place meaning is what you
decide it is life has the value that you
ascribe to it if you so I had this I had
this phase when I was younger where I
was like what's the point of anything
where does this all go and then I
thought to myself if this doesn't go
anywhere
then there's nothing holding me back
from trying to do the best things I can
in terms of what this world considers to
be good like positive and constructive
and then I meet a lot of people a lot of
left activists especially who are
negative nihilists nothing matters so
why don't we just Burn It Down for fun
right you can think nothing matters I
have no problem with that it's what do
you do next for me it was like if there
is no inherent mattering to anything
that means we assign that value we
decide and if I decide I'm going to
decide on good things making people feel
better giving them good long-term
Solutions longevity Family Life creation
exploration those are all good things
I'm with you on the positive nihilist
thing because I'm the same way because I
see a lot of meaninglessness in the
world and I'm finding meaning in my
family and in my own religion that I'm
working on but like I think what we can
agree on is we see a hope in people
whereas the negative nihilus want to
destroy people and themselves and that's
where the anti-human anti-future comes
in and I think the positive nihilists
as more rare as it might be I'd imagine
like my view of the world is I wouldn't
call it absolute nihilism I would say I
do see a lot of things as being
meaningless but I do think there is
meaning to us why we are here why humans
exist and so I would I would find myself
more in agreement with a staunch
conservative like you know Christian or
religious person who who genuinely
believes in larger purpose and something
bigger than themselves I'm like halfway
there that's why I say I believe in God
but I'm not like religiously theistic or
anything if you are someone who believes
there's no meaning but that if that's
the case we should be the best people we
can be because we made the meaning like
if you if you don't think there's a God
of morality and you think nothing
matters and then you decide from that I
want to make sure everybody lives the
best they can because it's up to us to
decide I think that kind of person is
going to be more aligned with people of
faith and religion who who are of a
similar not saying everybody every
religious person is a good person right
oh yeah of course not so saying the good
people of faith and the good people of
positive impact will work together with
smiles on their faces despite my
nihilism even it might be mostly
positive I believe in Free Will and I
think a lot of people who are negative
nihilists are determinists who believe
that there's no everything's set out for
them so there's no point to their life
um and I know those people personally
and I'm I I argue with them on the ideas
of Free Will and determinism I think
determinism is another anti-human idea
that means you're stuck in whatever path
you're in and there's no point these
people have no fight out of their
negativity it it
it bums me out oh yeah like I've told
this story you know I'd Occupy Wall
Street there was this prominent writer
and we had a Converse like they were
nasty to me and they were smack talking
and then when we talked in private is
this woman and she was very much just
like oh I don't care about anything I'm
an ilist it's just fun and I was like
well look like I agree with you that for
a lot of people like you look through
life you look at everything and you ask
yourself to what end if I do this then
what if I have kids then what if I build
this then what what's the point why not
do something else and I was like so I I
take from that the desire to build
something positive that has a good
result that grows and she goes yeah but
if it doesn't matter then isn't it just
fun to burn it all down and I'm like not
really people suffer from that and if
there are people who do have meaning in
life and you're causing them pain pain
is bad but this was the mentality of
these like antifa types oh yeah that's
why they don't care to throw a brick
through a window it feels good and who
cares it doesn't matter anyway I'm into
seeing the establishment burn like
that's fine to return type of power to
the people
I mean that wholeheartedly yeah but like
when you say burn the simulation down
well yeah because I don't believe I
don't believe the simulation like how
Elon believes it like in his videos I
mean that they've put a organ organic
organism simulation on top of our base
reality and that should go because it's
it's stripping us of uh our free will
you say in a video game but I just want
to point out like if maybe we are in a
video if it was possible okay look if it
was possible to set a fire to the code
that is the universe you know we'd be in
very serious trouble if someone could
like I'm going like burning on the
simulation is a figurative statement
that just means like you know it depends
how you view the simulation yeah you
know maybe the Large Hadron Collider is
a way to burn down a type of simulation
it'd be funny if the Large Hadron
Collider is like there's a bunch of
global Elites who genuinely believe
we're in a simulation and they're trying
to like manipulate code they're trying
to like like I mean that may be a way to
view it it's like the code of the
universe they're trying to manipulate
it's possible could you have the people
who've opened up portal who said they've
been with portals who bring in beasts
through other dimensions so I don't know
I I've heard some crazy Ayahuasca
stories yeah right and how much of that
is in their minds and how much is like
is that really Beyond the Veil or
whatever do you think there's a layer to
a lot of this
um a bigger kind of abuse stuff when it
comes to the spiritual war that's
happening out there because we know
there's people like uh Brina brovich
that do Spirit cooking we know that
there's a lot of rituals we know that
there's a lot of also individuals that
believe in in kind of a satanic order
have you seen anything uh like this from
your line of work or have anything to to
kind of add to that
I have not so I don't really just by
happenstance it's not that I don't
haven't tried or actively tried or not
tried I know individuals who have
experienced abuse with some of that but
uh but I haven't served any survivors
specifically that have faced that type
of abuse I think um
the Survivor that actually had had the
organization that saved my life Eve's
Angels kind of delves into some of that
there's there's some survivors that I
know like Rose McGowan kind of comes
from a darker childhood we're friends
um
but it seems like almost everything it's
evil yes do I think there's um something
like a deeper energetic spiritual war to
all of this of course I I think there is
I think yes
as I get older things start to feel more
like demonic yeah and and like holy or
light when I was younger I I genuinely
was like there's no such thing as good
or evil there's just people of different
perspectives and Views and then I get
older I learn more I travel more I've
been to other countries and then I'm
just like reading these stories and I
was like these people are evil and and
it's it's it may be hard to understand
because it oversimplifies
but I think you get old enough and you
look at the behaviors of certain
individuals and you realize there is
nothing pure there is just Mal intent it
is a Darkness within them this is why
individuals like you know Jeffrey
Epstein and Bill Gates were connected
together because they believed that
there was too many people on this Earth
and that they were all both eugenesis
they all believed in of course having
um you know a class of individuals
Epstein was doing a lot of human
experimentation and a lot of scientific
projects especially when it came to him
cloning a large portion of of the earth
a lot of weird stuff was going on yes he
had
um he had one of his scientific
experiments that we actually know about
was that he was trying to get as many
women as he could so he could impregnate
them at the same time in order to spread
his genes everywhere so that's that's
literally what these people are up to
that's literally some of the thinking
that goes into it some people say it's
because they just have too much money
too much power too much control and they
just do things in order to get some kind
of feeling and effect from it because
everything is meaningless to them or
some people say that they've been
overcome and and taken over by larger
spiritual demonic forces that they're
acting on beheads of and they've been
kind of hijacked by them and they're
kind of doing their bidding so whatever
you may believe on this particular topic
I think there's a reason that they do
have a lot of these kind of uh
ceremonies a lot of these kind of larger
actions a lot of the times bragging
about a lot of the stuff they do in
plain sight
um I I think there's you know I could go
further down the rabbit hole but I don't
want to do that on this show but it gets
the rabbit hole gets a lot deeper and
then it goes here yes there's a few
things that um brought me back to
believing in God years ago but one of
those things was when the Epstein news
broke I was like this is the most evil
thing that I could imagine like in my
time
um with the kids and stuff that if
there's something that evil there must
be a counter a good you know a balance
that because in nature I see balance I
see you know in the seasons Alone
um so that was like a big moment for me
when I remember it was like a beautiful
day too and I was just like it was so it
became so dark when I really went down
that rabbit hole and investigating that
story so I think I think that happened
for a lot of people I think it really uh
I think that story broke a lot of people
and I think that's why we sort of Saw
and I understand why I mean it's
devastating it's horrific on a scale
unimaginable but I think that's that
sort of breaking of the mind is sort of
why a lot of folks
went down a roll of following
um
I don't want to get you trouble queuing
on yeah they like went down that because
they're brain broken they're like if
that isn't true you know if that
happened then what else is happening you
know one of the things and I know Luke
will understand this like Epstein was
really bad the United States government
will bomb
millions of children and keep Wars going
you know kill kill Millions for a
paycheck
so I mean this Epstein absolutely
horrible many many survivors globally
many that we will never know their names
think about what what our own government
does as far as I consider our government
like a serial killer Well it's worse
yeah I mean on a massive scale right and
we fund it because I always think of
Tuskegee you know and stuff like that
just refunded the thousands the
thousands of survivors of the UN
globally at the hands of the UN you know
child exploitation sexual exploitation
and we fund them 22 humans and seven
percent sorry it seems like humans at
scale become sociopathic yeah I mean
look the U.S certainly is better than
basically everything else we've seen
throughout history we've done tremendous
in this country for advancing civil
rights yes you know different groups and
uh we have a great degree of Freedom
that many countries have never had but
that's that's thanks to the initial seed
planted of this country yeah you look at
all the dimensions Tuskegee MK Ultra I
mean there's a lot
aren't we oh yeah it's bad aren't humans
messy but but you look at Stalin you
look at communists you know uh I wonder
if it's powerful socio sociopaths rise
to power and and and just like I
shouldn't say sociopaths people have no
empathy in general people who just don't
care about you who view themselves as
God rise to power and then cause Mass
harm or is it just that when the machine
of humans collectivizes and becomes too
big they just have tremendous power that
causes harm in various ways without
accountability and without care right
it's probably both like I think I
mentioned this when Bryson was on but we
talked about Unit 731 with Japan what
they did to people which is I'll give
you an example they would take someone
and stick their arm through a hole into
Sub-Zero weather so their arm would
freeze while they were still alive
inside then they would pull their Frozen
arm in and shatter it with a hammer yes
I believe Vivid section is something I
also did where they would open up
someone watch the organs work and then
make them eat themselves but uh what I
was gonna say is there are people in
there who probably just part of the
system who get chewed up on both sides
obviously but then there are people in
charge like I forget his name but he
ended up becoming like a giant uh a CEO
of a big pharmaceutical company I forget
what it was at this point but it became
a huge one in Japan so I think there's a
mixture of greed with those people the
power and then they just have a lot of
people that they um they can control
it's crazy stuff man oh it's evil Angela
mcgirdle from the libertarian party put
up a Super Chat
yeah she gave you a shout out did she
yeah yeah that's one of my besties oh
that's awesome shout out to you Angela
and actually shout out to my cousin
Nathan
he's a big fan of yours Tim sick all
right on he saw me on the last I should
tell you guys the story
um he saw me on the last episode and he
didn't know anything about any of this
whole thing
and we were at his mother's funeral and
he's rather shy and we haven't talked a
lot but we don't have any beef we just
don't talk a lot he's a pretty shy
person and
um it was at his mother's funeral
unfortunately she passed away
and the first thing I think he's ever
really said to me that was like
he was like cyan Scion tube cast that
was weird I was like yeah that was weird
but it was kind of cute because we had a
bonding moment on such a rough day yeah
and um so yeah that's been one thing
that's kind of been weird about stepping
forward is like now my family
knows everything and uh but let's I'm
sorry you should you should finish the
thought sorry no you're good I was about
to ramble and you probably saved me
something actually Tim but let's talk
about Elon and Twitter before we go
because folks might not know that story
and it's awesome which one what happened
Let's uh the fact that I worked my butt
off for two years to get to to get
Twitter to make changes and begged and
begged and I did it all by myself with
no government help and no money and no
support from any organization I did it
all on my own and got the attention of
Elon Musk who purchased the platform and
then made the issued priority number one
I think that's a good story did you have
Silence from the previous Twitter
Administration uh Jack Dorsey did help
me out um a little bit but it wasn't
enough yeah and um yeah Elon Musk Elon
Musk has been absolutely incredible he's
been gracious he's been kind he's gone
above and beyond to support me and to
implement new suggestions and I don't
know what this new hit piece is about
but uh I can just assume it's in the
least favorable
um light and I don't remember them doing
such deep investigative journalism while
I was out here screaming those past two
years
um with two plus years actually but it
was really learning about the story of
John the one and John Doe two that uh
sort of set me on that Crusade and I'm
so grateful to Elon Musk for even
listening to me
um and starting to implement some
changes thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time